what were the early days like like being
around cube back then like obviously
both of you guys are from the same you
know the same set early days with me and
cute me and q went back when before ged
me and q we used to work together we
used to live together in compton
like we from the 50s like like it go
before ged like one day at work he just
was like i rap
i'm like you rap i'm like where are you
guys working
he was working at some like [ __ ]
railroad company or some crazy [ __ ] you
know what i'm saying manual labor yeah
manual labor loading the trains and all
that me and him just you know
and he from like he from 51st street i'm
from 56th street and i didn't know this
[ __ ] until he got to work and i'm like
where you live or where you from and i'm
like [ __ ] i stay right there i'm like
for how many years he like and i'm like
[ __ ] never
i'm like never [ __ ] we even went to the
same high school like he graduated
christian i graduated crenshaw he's in
the ninth grade you know i'm saying i
was in the 12th grade but i'm like how
the [ __ ] did we not see each other all
the way till we got here i mean but
that's just how the universe work energy
work whatever was he always hilarious my
[ __ ] was always funny he was always
doing the same [ __ ] he might be the most
underrated like comedic personality in
all the music but that's how all my
homies is that's how i am that's how you
are i mean look and now it's working
yeah i mean if we get together it's
unstoppable it's the jokes is ridiculous
but it's it's a cool
10 of us like that's just crazy like you
can't [ __ ] with it at all why did the uh
ged thing not work out like with queue
and tiger you know eventually obviously
ended up with tde um but just because of
the way
tiger do business exactly why i'm right
here you know i'm saying just the way
hot [ __ ] handle business and how
[ __ ] just be like out for self i mean
you can only do so much for a
[ __ ] i mean you don't owe me
[ __ ] but at the end of the day it's kind
of like
certain [ __ ] you supposed to do as a
friend you know what i'm saying and and
that's what it was with him like he knew
like his career wouldn't flourish with
ged he would he should he was he should
go over here to tde and this is where
it's at and that's where he decided to
stay hustle and grind you feel me and
then
t raw he did his own thing over here and
you know he he flourished his way it was
hard as [ __ ] too don't get it [ __ ] up
even though he was signing well he had
to kind of force force cash on his hand
yeah you had him on the shelf and he
heated up with all the mixtapes and it
was like
yeah but it wasn't even
as far as you being on the shelf because
it was just it wasn't even that but like
he was never like like i feel like you
guys forced
like universal's hand like with that
song yeah and coming out with [ __ ] and
doing mixtapes
done [ __ ] it was a different time back
then
and back then nobody was assigned to
young money until lil wayne went to jail
he signed all the artists when he went
to jail right before he went to jail so
he can lock everybody in so yeah so they
didn't so around that time we really
wasn't even we've just said [ __ ] were
saying young money in cash money nobody
was signed wow nobody was signed until
that [ __ ] had to go to jail